>>> ISRAEL'S MILITARY HAS
ADMITTED FOR THE FIRST TIME THAT
AL JAZEERA JOURNALIST SHIRRENE
ABU AKLEH WAS LIKELY KILLED BY
GUNFIRE.
RELEASED ON MONDAY CONCLUDING
THAT ABU AKLEH'S DEATH WAS AN
ACCIDENT.
SHE WAS KILLED IN MAY COVERING
AN ISRAELI OPERATION IN THE WEST
BANK.
SAYING THERE'S A HIGH
POSSIBILITY THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE,
THEY DON'T INTEND TO PURSUE
CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST THE
SOLDIER RESPONSIBLE.
IN A STATEMENT, THEY SAID THE
SOLDIERS DID NOT KNOW THEY WERE
FIRING AT THE PRESS, INSTEAD OF
FIRING BACK AT MILITANTS.
EVIDENCE, THOUGH, FROM THE
INVESTIGATION REVEALED THERE WAS
NO ACTIVE COMBAT OR PALESTINIAN
MILITANTS NEAR WHERE ABU AKLEH
WAS STANDING.
SHE WAS ALSO WEARING A VEST
IDENTIFYING HER AS PRESS BOTH ON
HER FRONT AND HER BACK.
ABU AKLEH'S FAMILY SLAMMING THE
REPORT ON MONDAY SAYING, QUOTE,
TRYING TO OBSCURE THE TRUTH AND
AVOID RESPONSIBILITY.
JOINING US NOW IS SHIRRENE'S
SISTER NINA.
HOW ARE YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
REACTING TO THIS NEWS?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
OUR FAMILY, YOU KNOW, WE WERE
NOT EXPECTING THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT OR ARMY TO HOLD
THEMSELVES RESPONSIBLE.
THIS IS WHAT WE WERE EXPECTING
AT THE END.
AND IT'S HONESTLY -- IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT.
IT'S BEEN VERY UPSETTING AND
FRUSTRATING.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, THE
STATEMENT IS JUST TRYING TO
OBSCURE THE TRUTH AND AVOID
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE KNOW THE TRUTH.
WE KNOW THE FACT AS YOU STATED,
MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS
HAVE CONCLUDED THAT SHIREEN WAS
SHOT AND ATTACKED BY SOLDIERS
AND WEARING A PROTECTIVE VEST.
AND IT WAS CLEARLY MARKED PRESS
IN THE FRONT AND BACK.
YET, THEY WERE ABLE TO PRECISELY
AIM IN BETWEEN THE AREA OF HER
HELMET AND HER VEST.
SO IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING THAT
UNTIL THIS DAY THERE HASN'T BEEN
ANY ACCOUNTABILITY FROM THE U.S.
IF THE U.S. TRULY BELIEVES IN
ACCOUNTABILITY, THEN THERE NEEDS
TO BE ACTION.
THIS TODAY, MORE THAN EVER, THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE CALLING IS FOR, A
U.S. INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION.
ISRAELI CRIMINALS CANNOT BE
INVESTIGATING THEIR OWN CRIMES.
>> WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE TO
YOU, WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
AN INDEPENDENT U.S.
INVESTIGATION?
>> YEAH, SHIREEN WAS A U.S.
CITIZEN.
SHE DESERVES A U.S.-LED
INVESTIGATION.
IT NEEDS TO BE INDEPENDENT,
TRANSPARENT.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE CONDUCTED BY
THE FBI, THE SAME AS IT'S DONE
IN OTHER CASES WHEN A U.S.
CITIZEN IS KILLED ABROAD.
YOU KNOW, THE U.S. FUNDS THE
ISRAELI MILITARY, ANNUALLY,
AROUND $4 BILLION.
IT'S NOT JUST US WHO ARE CALLING
FOR THIS INVESTIGATION, BUT ALSO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, SENATORS,
REPRESENTATIVES, WHO ARE WORRIED
THAT OUR MONEY, OUR TAXPAYER
MONEY IS GOING INTO THE FUNDING
OF KILLING THE U.S. CITIZEN.
U.S. INVESTIGATION WILL HOLD THE
ISRAELI
AND THIS IS WHAT JUSTICE WILL
LOOK LIKE FOR US, CHANGING THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM THAT CONTINUES TO
PERPETUATE THIS KIND OF
VIOLENCE.
>> LINA, I WANT TO ASK YOU TO
REACT TO SOMETHING THAT WAS IN
THIS REPORT.
YOU SAID IN THIS REPORT ISRAEL
SAYS THERE WAS NO SUSPICION OF A
CRIMINAL OFFENSE THAT WARRANTS
THE OPENING OF AN INVESTIGATION.
SO, THEY'RE FINDING THAT
OBVIOUSLY THIS HAPPENED.
THE INITIAL STORY WAS IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN PALESTINIANS OR IT WAS
LIKELY PALESTINIAN FIRE.
THE STORY HAS MIGRATED
CONSIDERABLY.
NOW IT'S HIGH POSSIBILITY IT'S
ISRAELI FIRE.
SOMEONE AT THE TIME, IT SEEMS,
WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THERE WAS
A POSSIBILITY THAT IT WAS
ISRAELI FIRE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HOW LONG IT
TOOK ISRAEL TO COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION AFTER COMING TO THESE
OTHER CONTRASTING CONCLUSIONS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, FROM DAY ONE
THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT, ISRAELI
ARMY, THEY CHANGED THEIR
NARRATIVE OVER SEVEN TIMES.
AND FOUR MONTHS LATER WHEN
EVERYONE HAS BEEN SAYING THE
SAME THING FROM DAY ONE, THE
ISRAELI SOLDIERS HAVE KILLED
SHIREEN, THEY STILL ARE NOT
HOLDING THEMSELVES RESPONSIBLE.
THERE'S STILL NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY CLAIM IT WAS PROBABLY AN
ISRAELI SOLDIER.
IN A WAY, IT IS ADOPTING THE
SAME U.S. STATEMENT THAT WAS
RELEASED ON FOURTH OF JULY,
SAYING THAT IT'S PROBABLY
ISRAELI SOLDIERS.
SO IN A WAY THEY STILL CONTINUE
TO AVOID RESPONSIBILITY AND
OBSCURING THE TRUTH, AND THEM
HOLDING THEIR SOLDIERS
ACCOUNTABLE WILL LEAD INTO --
INTO GREATER CONCERNS FOR THEM,
SUCH AS AN ICC INVESTIGATION,
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE CALLING FOR
THE ICC TO ALSO INTERVENE AND
CARRY OUT AN INVESTIGATION.
BUT, OF COURSE, TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WE HAVE SEEN HOW THERE IS
A TRACK RECORD OF ISRAEL
ESCAPING RESPONSIBILITY, AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CONTINUING TO
ENJOY THAT IMPUNITY.
THAT'S WHY WE CONTINUE TO CALL
FOR AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION.
>> LOOK, THERE IS A CHASM HERE
BETWEEN YOUR VIEW, OBVIOUSLY,
AND ISRAEL'S.
ISRAEL'S DENYING THAT SOLDIERS
TARGETED HER, TARGETED PRESS,
TARGETED CIVILIANS.
CLEARLY THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU OR YOUR FAMILY BELIEVES
AND SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THIS STORY.
LINA ABU AKLEH, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.